depuis les premiers attentats début
juillet la vie quotidienne à londres est
difficile entre fausses alertes contrôle
de police fermeture de stations de métro
les londoniens doivent changer leurs
habitudes
et depuis quelques temps les ventes de
vélos ont augmenté de plus en plus de
gens se rendent au travail à bicyclette
pour éviter de prendre les transports en
commun alexandra garde depuis le 7
juillet corinna warm a ressorti son
ancienne bicyclette remisé au garage
pour se rendre au travail
pas question pour cette jeune
londonienne de revivre les froids et l'
angoisse ressenti pendant les attentats
anxieux et découragés comme elle par les
perturbations qui touchent encore le
métro
les londoniens sont de plus en plus
nombreux à se mettre au vélo je n'aimais
pas le vélo mais quand je suis assis
dans le métro je suis soupçonneux je
regarde les gens comme des terroristes
en puissance
j'ai l'esprit plus libre mais sous
contrôle mon propre destin bradbury qui
tient un magasin de cycles dans le
centre de londres raconte n'avoir jamais
vendu autant de vélos que depuis ces
explosions meurtrières
ils partent comme des petits pains en
rapport londonien parle même d'une
augmentation de 20 % puis de 7 juillet
je n'arrête pas de louer des vélos c'est
la première fois que ça m'arrive
les gens entraient disant qu'ils ne
veulent plus utiliser les transports
publics qu'ils cherchent un nouveau
moyen de transport qu'ils veulent
acheter un vélo pris d'assaut dès le
maintenant les taxis londoniens affiche
des files ininterrompues et
démoralisante le vélo est donc la seule
alternative pour l'instant est aussi une
bonne initiative je crois que c'est bien
c'est comme en hollande et dans les
autres pays d'europe
ça va faire du bien long
la circulation sans fil personnellement
boudé jusqu'à présent dans la capitale
londonienne la petite reine serait-elle
de retour c'est tout le bien qu'on
souhaite à une ville meurtrie